impressive young man  anthropomorphing into the backfield and  here comes a  reverse and then a throw  and it's anthropology got the handoff  that gets the catch and he's loose  inside the 25 reversing field inside the  15 gets a block inside the 10 to the end  zone touchdown purdue  [Applause]  that play took about two minutes  by the time it started to the time it  finished in the end zone tire offensive  line out in front blocking for jackson  anthrop again the amount of time this  takes and the execution of the play look  at this offensive line out in front  burying michigan state defenders and  then the rest is anthropo in the open  field  as he takes it to the house nice job by  david bell getting just enough